>> Sean: JOINING US NOW, HE IS
THE HOST OF THE UPCOMING
FOX NEWS SHOW "LIFE, LIBERTY,
TIME.
WE HAVE TWO DOSSIERS, TWO MEMOS
FROM GRASSLEY'S COMMITTEE
NUNES MORA PHONE INFORMATION,
AND FUNDING THIS PHONY, RUSSIAN
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEN USED AS A BASIS IN PART FOR
A FISA WARRANT AGAINST A
CANDIDATE AND AN INCOMING
GREAT ONE.
I COULDN'T WRITE A NOVEL THIS
BAD.
>> AND THIS IS BAD.
LET ME TELL YOU A COUPLE OF
THINGS HERE.
NOW WE KNOW WHY SCHIFF AND THE
REST OF THEM ARE FIGHTING SO
PRAETORIAN GUARD DEMOCRAT MEDIA
ARE FIGHTING SO HARD, TRASHING
NUNES, ME, YOU, AND OTHERS.
LET'S WALK THROUGH THIS QUICKLY.
WHO ARE THEY TRYING TO PROTECT?
HILLARY CLINTON.
SEAN, WHO ELSE ARE THEY TRYING
TO PROTECT?
BARACK OBAMA.
HIS NAME NEVER COMES UP.
LET ME HELP EVERYBODY WITH
EXPERIENCED LORETTA LYNCH KNEW
ABOUT THESE FISA WARRANTS.
YATES, THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THE EXTENSIONS
REPRESENTING, NOW THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL  .
HE KNEW.
FBI DIRECTOR COMEY, McCADE,
WARRANTS?
THESE ARE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
WARRANTS.
YOU HAVE TO ASSUME THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL AND THE
WHITE HOUSE NEW.
WHY WOULD THE FBI, JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, KEEP THAT FROM THE
NATIONAL SECURITY DIRECTOR IN
THE WHITE HOUSE?
WHITE HOUSE?
SO WHY WOULD BE LEFT OUT OF THE
PRESIDENT'S DAILY INTELLIGENCE
BRIEFING -- [CLEARING THROAT]
CONGRESS ALSO NEEDS TO GET A
HOLD OF.
I AM TELLING YOU, LOOKING AT THE
FBI, LOOKING AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, WE ARE NOT LOOKING
AT ALL AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR A
WARRANT.
HILLARY CLINTON COLLUDED WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
BUT IT APPEARS THE FBI AT THE
SENIORMOST LEVELS COLLUDED WITH
THE RUSSIANS TOO.
WHETHER IT WAS WITTING OR
UNWITTING, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THAT'S A FACT.
THE SENIOR LEVEL OF THE FBI
TRIED TO INTERFERE WITH THIS
SELECTION AS WELL.
THIS IS WHY IT'S SUCH A BIG
DEAL.
I KNOW REPUBLICANS ARE BENDING
OVER BACKWARDS SAYING THIS HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH MUELLER.
THIS HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
MUELLER!
X MAKE A TRANSITION FROM
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AFTER COMEY, OF
ALL THINGS, CONVENTIONS
ALL THINGS, CONVENTIONS        C
ALL THINGS, CONVENTIONS        N
ALL THINGS, CONVENTIONS        E
ALL THINGS, CONVENTIONS        S
ALL THINGS, CONVENTIONS        F
ALL THINGS, CONVENTIONS        R
ALL THINGS, CONVENTIONS        A
ALL THINGS, CONVENTIONS        L
THINGS.
MUELLER IS THE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR!
THAT IS HIS ENVIRONMENT.
HE'S NOT OUT THERE AS SOME
INDEPENDENT PORTS.
BUT I WANT TO GET BACK TO
BARACK OBAMA.
IT'S HIS FBI.
HE IS CANDIDATE.
I CANNOT BELIEVE FOR A MINUTE
THAT THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THIS.
AND TO SHOW YOU HOW ELABORATE
THIS IS, NOW THAT MORE
INFORMATION IS COMING OUT, WE
HAVEN'T EVEN GOTTEN TO THE
INCIDENTAL COLLECTION OF
INTELLIGENCE ON PEOPLE,
INCLUDING, BY THE WAY, SESSIONS
WHEN HE MET WITH AND SPOKE WITH
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR, THE
UNMASKING AND LEAKING OF HIS
NAME, THE RECORD NUMBER OF
UNMASKING OF AMERICAN CITIZENS
IN THE TRUMP WORLD AND SO FORTH
MASSIVE PROPAGANDA, THIS
INFORMATION CAMPAIGN BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN, BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
LET ME ASK YOU A LOGICAL
QUESTION, SEAN.
WHY WOULD THE RUSSIANS WANT
DONALD TRUMP TO BE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WHEN THEY
COULD GET EVERYTHING THEY WANT
FROM HILLARY CLINTON, WHETHER
IT'S URANIUM, WHETHER IT'S
UNDERMINING DEFENSE BY CUTTING
MILITARY SPENDING, BY REFUSING
TO SECURE OUR BORDER ON THE
LIGHT IN THE WORLD WITH THE
RUSSIANS WANT TRUMP AS OPPOSED
TO HILLARY CLINTON --
B1 LET ME JUMP IN JUST A SECOND.
IF WE WERE REALLY TO GET THE
FISA APPLICATION, GETTING RID OF
SOURCES AND METHODS, IF WE WERE
ABLE TO MAKE PUBLIC BARACK OBAMA
ABLE TO MAKE PUBLIC BARACK OBAM
BARACK OBAMA'S PRESIDENTIAL
BRIEFING, YOU ARE BETTING, AND I
AGREE WITH YOU, TONIGHT, IT
WOULD CLEARLY SHOW THAT HE KNEW
PROPAGANDIST OUT THERE, THEY
DON'T HAVE BEEN ROADS OUT THERE,
VALERIE JARRETT OUT THERE.
BARACK OBAMA'S GOING IN THE
WITNESS PROTECTION PROGRAM
DURING THE BAND KNOWS WHERE HE
IS ANYMORE.
HIS NAME NEVER COMES UP.
I'M TELLING YOU THAT THE
FRENZIED DEFENSE OF WHAT'S
PROTECT OBAMA.
ONE HAS THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
SUPPORT LAW ENFORCEMENT?
THEY UNDERMINED THE BALTIMORE
DEPARTMENT, THE NYPD, THE
L.A.P.D., ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY
ARE DEFENDING THE FBI.
AND THEY TURN AROUND AND SAY,
WHY ARE YOU ATTACKING THE FBI?
YOU AND I AND OTHERS -- [CLEAR
THROAT,"]
DEFENDING THE FBI AGAINST THE
SENIOR LEVEL.
THE LEAKING!
WE ALREADY KNOW, COMEY IS A
LEAKER, SUITE 24 IS A LEAKER,
STROK IS A LEAKER, PAIGE IS A
LEAKER, IT'S HOW WE KNEW ON
MARCH 2ND, 5TH, 6 OF LAST YEAR,
SOMETHING WAS WRONG.
WE GOT A LITTLE BIT OF SPEED
WHENEVER INFORMATION BEING
LEAKED, WE GOT STUFF ABOUT
AMONG OTHERS.
AND THEN IT ALL NOW MAKES SENSE.
THIS IS A MASSIVE SPECTACLE.
YOU ARE A HISTORIAN.
>> WHETHER IT IS OR NOT, THE
FACTS...
LISTEN.
NOT ONLY DO WE NEED A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, WE NEED A COMMISSION.
I WAS TALKING TO MY WIFE ABOUT
HE'S RIGHT.
WE NEEDED CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, WE NEED A POLICY
WE CANNOT WALK AWAY FROM THIS.